-Our next guest is a
talented actor who you know from
films such as "Mudbound,"
"Chappaquiddick,"
and "Zero Dark Thirty."
You can catch him in
the highly anticipated series
"Winning Time:
The Rise of the Lakers Dynasty,"
premiering March 6th on
HBO and streaming on HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-You know what?
Cooke sent me out there
to be his star, too.
Got me to sell his tickets,
and every year, when we lost,
he still cashed his checks,
but I'm the one
that's got to live with it.
I'm the one that's got to have
the nightmares
with these
Boston Irish mother[bleep]
running the floor.
-The always-hustling,
always-chasing Jerry West
with a final tally
that was heartbreaking.
-Do you think I like that?
-A series that could have
truly gone either way.
-I can still smell
the halitosis.
Do you have any idea
what that's like?
-Please welcome back
to the show
Jason Clarke, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, Jason.
-I tell you what,
I'm keeping up
the sartorial standard here
on the show, aren't I?
-I mean, you're setting a way
higher bar than the rest of us.
-No, I saw Oliver out there.
I should have come
'90s Australian plumber,
and I did
'70s Italian industrialist.
-Yeah, there's, like, a
shipping-magnate vibe to you.
It's really nice.
-Cashmere socks, Seth.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Cashmere socks?
You didn't get the memo that
we're slummin' it these days.
-No, I know.
I should have put the
Blundstones on and the RMs, eh?
-You -- I want to ask, because,
one of the most fun parts,
I would imagine, about playing
this era Jerry West
on the show is the sort of
sartorial choices
he made in the '80s.
It's a fun --
The look of this show
is sort of all
the joyful colors of that.
This is --
That's real Jerry West.
They really --
You did a good job there.
-No, they did.
They bought -- Because he was
into Missoni sweaters,
and they bought these beautiful
Missoni knits off of eBay,
you know, resellers that were
original from the period.
It was -- I mean,
everyone had their style.
Big, white feather coats
going on.
I mean, it's
Magic mother[bleep] Johnson.
-Yeah.
And it's a fantastic cast.
Did you know much --
I mean, obviously,
you grew up in Australia.
Did you know much about
the '80s Lakers?
Do you ever go to
the Lakers games now?
-Yeah, I went last night
with John Reilly.
-Alright, look at that.
-Yeah.
-John C. Reilly,
who's fantastic in this.
-Yeah. Gets a lot of love, John.
He really does.
-Yeah, he's -- Yeah.
-He gets a lot of love.
It was funny,
because it was a bad --
The lakers played terribly.
I mean, terribly.
Mike Tyson left at halftime.
-Yeah.
-And it was --
Because I was there with John
and, you know, young Quincy,
who's playing Magic,
and DeVaughn,
who's Norm Nixon's son.
And they got their butts kicked.
-Yeah. That's not good.
You guys are a jinx.
-But, you know,
the biggest thing I knew was
when Magic was
diagnosed HIV-positive,
which is where our show
kind of ends,
in the flashback
at the beginning.
And then he played in
Barcelona at the Olympics.
-Yeah.
-And in Australia, we had these
ads with the Grim Reaper
for AIDS bowling the ball down,
and, you know,
it was very doom and gloom,
and maybe rightly so.
But there he was, you know,
6'10" of him
playing, you know,
with the Dream Team,
and everyone
was playing with him, you know?
And he was living with it.
And it was like, "Oh, wow.
There's another
world out there, as well,"
which is -- You know,
it was one of those things that,
even in Australia,
little, old country boy
from Australia went,
"Look at this dude, man.
Look at him."
-And you were really a
country boy from Australia.
Your dad was a sheep shearer.
Is that --
-Yes, he was. Yeah.
-That sounds like the punch line
of a joke about somebody.
Did he think that acting was
a noble profession?
Like, how does somebody --
[ Laughter ]
-I was the butt
of a lot of jokes in my
wider-ranging family
for a long time.
-Yeah. Like, how did you
even approach to him
that this was going to be a path
you wanted your life to take?
-You know,
it was kind of like --
I mean, my dad is
the loveliest, gentlest man,
who had a very rough upbringing.
He just didn't know
that it was a path.
-Yeah.
-He didn't know that it
was a profession.
You know, it was like -- I was
doing an interview with --
The shows are very different.
I mean, you know, Australian
interview the other day
was saying,
"Oh, you're playing Jerry West."
You know,
and all the other guys,
the Americans on the panel,
are going,
"Wow, you know, Jerry --"
And, "You look like
Frankie J. Holden."
And nobody would know who
Frankie J. Holden is.
He's this Australian actor
from the '70s.
But it's always taking it back
to that small time,
"How does this relate
to Australia?"
So, my father had no idea,
you know, that being an actor
was a profession
and it's something you could do.
-Like, once you took that path
and once you sort of met
with some success,
was he happy for you?
Was he excited?
-Yeah.
He's a big golfer,
and I've gotten him onto some
golf courses, yeah.
-Oh, there you go.
So it's a real quid pro quo
situation, yeah.
-No, it was,
because Jerry West was
a big golfer, as well.
He actually held the back-nine
record, I think, at Bel-Air.
And the pictures
that my father loved the best,
when I'd send him, you know,
was in the '80s golf gear,
you know?
I mean, the colors
were just magnificent.
The tight, checked pants.
You know, the white shoes
and the socks,
I mean, and, you know,
the big, gold watches,
and the ring, of course,
his one ring.
-And you also -- I should note,
there are some flashbacks,
and you got to play Jerry West
the basketball player,
not the executive.
-In the tight shorts.
-Yeah, well,
that's my question.
-Yeah. I worked my buns for
a long time, dude.
-Yeah. Well, it shows up.
I just want to tip my cap.
You know, the work you put in
pays off.
-A bit funny, though, because I
have very bandy legs.
My legs are very bowed.
-Yeah.
-And it's because my father said
he grew up on a horse,
so I must have come out
the same way.
Because before he was a shearer,
he was a drover as a young boy.
He had to drive cattle across
Australia at like 7 and 8.
-They make you
drive cattle at --
-Well, he did.
Yeah, it's some tough love.
He got an orange
for Christmas, dude.
Between eight of them.
I mean, and that's a fact.
He did.
He goes, "We got an orange
for Christmas.
There was eight of us."
-I can't believe, by the way --
Like, you can never complain
about work to him.
You can't be like, "Oh, my God,
we had a 14-hour day on set."
-No.
-He's like, "Got that orange."
-But I did send him a picture
of me in the gear, you know,
the knitted top and the shorts.
And all him and mum pointed out
and laughed at
was my bandy legs.
"Oh, we showed everyone, Jason."
"Well, I said not to show
anybody, because --"
They looked at those legs,
you know?
Yep. And I thought, "Well,
what about my upper torso?
Didn't I look muscly?"
-No. That's --
Parents will often find --
Yeah, well,
maybe he's just proud that you
have his bandy
legs, and he just went --
-You know what, Seth?
I think he is.
I do hope my sons
don't have them, though.
-Yeah. Is it too early to tell
if your sons have your legs?
Because I know one of my kids
has my legs, 100%.
-Does he?
-Yeah.
-My youngest has got my hands,
my short, stubbly,
working-man hands.
My oldest has got my wife's
longer, piano-playing fingers.
-That's so funny.
-But I think we've done
a personality swap.
You know what I mean?
One looks like me,
but he's his mother,
and one looks like my wife,
but he's me.
-That's great.
I feel like that's the most fun
possible outcome.
Yeah.
We're doing the same thing.
We were talking
a little bit about it.
I've got a 5-year-old
up on skis.
Your 5-year-old --
also up on skis.
Is he a good skier?
-You know, he did his second
time in France.
First, we went to Mammoth.
And he came off the mountain
after going up
on the lift, you know,
and my wife timed it there
so I'd catch him, you know?
He'd grown like 2 feet higher
in pride, you know?
"Papa! Papa!"
Smack! Straight into the thing.
And it's like, "Oh, no!"
"It's okay! I'm okay, Papa."
I'm okay!"
My wife's French,
so he calls me "Papa,"
which I love, rather than "Dad."
-Oh, that's really good.
-Yeah.
But you saddled up
for a third, dude.
-Yeah, we got a third.
-I feel inadequate.
-I was like --
I wanted to get a third.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. Yeah.
And I'm realizing now,
it's not too late to make her
call me "Papa."
The other two, it's lost.
It'd be great to have two
that call me "Dad"
and then a
little girl who's like, "Papa!"
-Papa, Papa!
-And then
I could always be like,
"That's why she gets my
attention, you two dopes.
Because she's charming."
-It's true, though, isn't it?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, there's something about
when your little kid
comes off a mountain
and he's taller,
and his pride
and he looks at you
and he just wants to let you --
"Did you see that?"
-It's really great.
Yeah, we -- Although,
I went down with him on Sunday,
because he can barrel down,
and we're working on turns.
And so we went down.
-Important.
-Yeah, yeah.
-"Dude, come back!
I can't come after you."
-And he was doing his turns,
and it was really good.
And I was filming him as he was
doing his turn, on the iPhone.
And then I realized,
"I'm going to break my neck."
Like, that's --
And he'll always be like,
"This is the first time
I did turns,
and that's when Daddy went off
the side of the mountain."
-"And that's Daddy going --"
Yeah.
And, there, he's going.
And he's still going.
He's still -- Yep.
Yep, he's still falling.
-He's still falling.
-Somebody will find
the phone later on.
-They're like, "Oh, God,
this video started so nice,
and then -- Yeah."
Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
It's always such a pleasure.
Congrats on the show.
-Thank you.
-Jason Clarke.
"Winning Time"
premieres March 6th
on HBO and streaming on HBO Max.